vous vous souvenez sans doute qu'une
étude de la firme secor pékin kepa pas
non kpmg nous avez montré que vous avez
pensé à quelque chose
pkp peut-être trop mauvais alors je vais
reprendre donc ma phrase pour qu'il n'y
a pas d'ambiguïté quand même vous vous
souviendrez sans doute qu'une étude de
la firme kpmg
j'entre je la trouve moi même assez
drôle tu sais pas nous avait démontré en
fait cette étude très sérieusement nous
avait démontré une réelle problématique
quant au respect des coûts planifié pour
les projets ainsi que de nombreuses
annonces non budgétées qu'avait effectué
par l'ancien gouvernement